what are the cowboys sort of represented
i've really not liked the cowboys since
coming out of the womb as a niner fan
but um
no i gotta i got a lot of respect for
those guys and they've actually had a
great winning organization
and um a lot of great players in their
history
uh guys that i just you know as a as a
niner fan i you know you play the
cowboys and every time they hand out
dammit smith be a five-yard game and you
would pull your hair out
that's tom brady earlier this week
talking about the looming showdown once
every four years with the dallas cowboys
in the regular season tom curran of nbc
sports boston covers the patriots he
joins us now hello tom how are you
mike i'm tremendous how are you
i think tremendous may be a bit of an
overstatement i've known you for a long
time tremendous is something i've never
thought of when i think tom curran
i'm over the moon personal best couldn't
be better
the patriots can't say the same thing at
least not offensively they can say it
defensively they can't say it
offensively how do you
reconcile this team because on one hand
they are as good of a defense as we've
seen arguably since the 2000 ravens on
the other hand the offense just has a
lot of holes and i i
i assume the defense is good enough to
cover up a lot of it but it's just kind
of a weird year for the patriots
it is a weird year and
you know this isn't what they intended
with the offense
but they had a lot of swings and misses
and it goes past antonio brown
um when you look at what they've done
over the last couple years
yes danny amendola and brandon cooks
left and there were reasons for that you
know with high contracts and cooks
with somebody they wouldn't resign they
got some collateral back but then gronk
retired they've not done anything at
tight end even though gronk has
intimated retirement since about you
know 2016
they haven't done anything at tight ends
in years except for giraffe ryan izzo 56
tight ends have come into the lane since
2015 the patriots draft up a
seventh-round pick out of florida state
a lot of swings and misses with jared
cook or austin safari and jenkins or
lance kendricks they finally settle in
on benjamin watson then on the wide
receiver side of things they haven't
really done much in the draft
and they've just thrown guys against the
wall
whether it's kenny britt or jordan
matthews
in free agency and then they've made
panic moves whether it be with antonio
brown or josh gordon last year so
they've spent a ton on defense haven't
done as much on offense and then they
kind of look at brady and mcdaniels and
say go figure it out well with the
injuries
the retirement of gronkowski a lot of
the poop has hit the fan michael and
they can't move the football and that's
why you see a level of frustration i
think outwardly people look at and say
well they just flipped the switch last
year they're going to do it this year
too right
i don't think they can
there's been a lot of fascination this
week about a potential return by antonio
brown he posted an apology on social
media to robert kraft and the
organization there's a sense of optimism
that the league now that it has
interviewed antonio brown will come to
the conclusion that that he should be
cleared and not suspended any further
because as a practical matter he's
served a nine-week suspension unpaid
while this process is unfolded
why do we think that this has bubbled up
about a possible reunion and do we think
there's any chance whatsoever that the
patriots would welcome back a guy who
was only there for a week
it
has any and we spoke about it for my
podcast yesterday and after that i spoke
to someone and they quashed it it's not
going to happen i had two sources tell
me that one earlier in the week
um who probably was a little far removed
for me to run with but after i spoke
later in the day
it pretty much quenched it he's not
going to be returning to the patriots
and the reason mike isn't because the
apology was insufficient
it has more to do with the fact that
when he signed initially with the
patriots
they went through the exercise of okay
is anything gonna bubble up here we're
gonna have an issue with anything
and they were told no
mainly because drew rosenhaus
was under the
feeling i think that they had it under
control the brittany taylor situation
was not going to explode on them yet it
did and the patriots view that as not
necessarily
um disqualifying for drew rosenhaus
going forward
he was trying to do what was best and he
thought he had it under control but he
didn't and that's what's going to
possibly happen with antonio brown
patriots don't want that grenade to go
off in their hand twice went off once
they don't want to put it in their left
hand now and have that blown off by
having something else emerge
so
it's once bitten twice shy and the
patriots are not going to be back in the
business of antonio brown as a result
and that makes a lot of sense tom
because when antonio brown filed his
paperwork in response to the lawsuit
that started all of this on september
10.
it became abundantly clear that brown
did know about this did know about the
possibility
months in advance so if you ask that
broad open-ended question is there
anything we need to know that is
something that the patriots would have
needed to know because if they had known
about it they probably wouldn't have
signed him in the first place now here's
the reality we talked about this on your
podcast yesterday
it's not a simple question of
either we take him or we don't
the other complication here is
someone else may are we comfortable with
the prospect of seeing antonio brown
playing for the ravens playing for the
chiefs playing maybe for a super bowl
opponent and that would seem to at least
weigh into the decision but it sounds
like even that doesn't matter they're
happy to face him as a member of some
other team they don't want the guy back
period
yeah and that when you say they i think
that that is presuming that it's
organization wide and look we reported
afterwards that it was a it was
not necessarily unanimous certainly
football wise
tom brady was not psyched about the idea
of antonio brown going elsewhere bill
belichick i think was reticent as well
eventually realizing i have to go along
to get along on this but it was not
something that he said yeah yeah yeah
this is definitely something we have to
do so
football wise they realize it's a risk
ownership wise
um or higher up the brand can't sustain
the same thing happening again but mike
here's the interesting thing when you
mention all those teams you don't
mention the raiders who are in
contention you don't mention the
steelers who are in contention and of
course the patriots are out of that all
those of the teams that brown has burned
in the last six months or eight months
and as a result
that's why
any of those teams who are going to hop
into bed with antonio brown better
understand that they might get out of
bed with a big problem
well they might not last very long with
him
but i don't disagree with that i didn't
mention the raiders of the steelers
because i don't think they are serious
enough contenders for a beat or one he's
gonna want to go to a team
right i don't really agree they don't do
it again because they they they get
screwed by them
right the teams the patriots in the
market forum
have not have not had the the antonio
brown experience yet
i don't disagree with that let me ask
you about the game coming up on sunday a
fairly significant one cowboys coming to
town bill belichick versus kellen moore
i mean when you break it down to that
it's a no-brainer right what do you
think the patriots defense will do what
will they take away from the dallas
offense because you can either go zeke
you can go dak what do you think they'll
do
that's the interesting thing you can do
those things the patriots are terrific
at it i would imagine staphon gilmore on
amari cooper is where you start
the issue to an extent is the fact that
dallas is so balanced
um and the patriots haven't faced a team
with so many different
quality players they have a slot
receiver they have a secondary receiver
in gallup they have mari cooper they
have um
they have the ability of ezekiel elliott
catch the ball out of the backfield so
they're unique in that they have whitney
who's still hanging around and doing
okay so
yes the patriots have been outstanding
yes they are not a paper tiger
but they will be stressed and this is
where it comes back to the offense and
complimentary football mike dallas
doesn't have to put up 37 points
if they put up 24k in the patriots keep
pace against a pretty good to
almost really good defense that dallas
has i don't know if they can i don't
know if the patriots can get over 20
against dallas so dallas doesn't have to
light it up
on offense and
stand in a good position to win the
football game
tom great stuff is always pal we will be
talking to you again soon enjoy the game
on sunday and have a great weekend
thank you kid
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports